yeah we destroyed the mlrs yeah the
Russian 200th Brigade was here it's so
absurd that they have a 200th Brigade
but also cool there to see soldiers
cargo 200. any connections with the
Russian Federation have been lost for
centuries I especially like watching the
video showing how they wrap their arms
and legs with medical harnesses I don't
know when they'll run out of these
mobilized they stop and turn around and
panic hi Mars hi Mars I thank God that I
had the chance to breathe the same air
with these guys
and that's it launched it's burning
Russians are running around fussing and
we're rejoicing and you like that we'll
push the Russians to the borders we'll
put up a fence and we'll dig a ditch and
let crocodiles in there and we'll also
take back Crimea
[Music]
thank you
we are now going to to kupians to visit
the 128th Battalion of the 112th Brigade
the soldiers the soldiers from this
brigade will guide us around kupiansk
and kupians
and tell us a little about how these
territories were liberated
this city is one of many we are visiting
in China
in general we will now record how things
are in cupions
when we came to cupians last time
was still under occupation in fact
journalists were not yet allowed
so it did not film any military
facilities or anything like that we
filmed people's reactions purely we had
the impression that everyone wanted to
talk let it all out because they did not
have such an opportunity for a long time
now we will talk to the military who
actually liberated these territories
last time we didn't quite succeed to be
honest and now we will actually be on
the other side of the Oscar River
armed forces of Ukraine are advancing
further we are trying to catch up and
film what we didn't have a chance to
film yet my name is
I'm the founder of Ukraine media and we
are going on the deoccupation expedition
to show how the deoccupation process is
taking place soon we will be traveling
around the liberated Crimea
[Music]
thank you guys I used to be a technical
director in an I.T company
had a house with a pool and the whole
deal
it was an excellent job Indeed the
company is still working everything is
fine my former colleagues helped me the
way they can no doubt it Specialists can
support a lot it comes hard for me to
talk about I.T life now though dimitro
told us that you used to work in the
tech field yes
turn left here
I used to believe that I was a very busy
person doing very important work however
now it seems that this was not quite the
case
such beautiful places there are
yes very beautiful
there were Fierce battles here
everything is ruined
we're now entering
the occupation was of course long and
hard
there were various divisions there were
constant battles for it who apart from
the 92nd Brigade operated here Croc and
regiment was here right yes uh Kraken
was here
specifically here there were only the
92nd Brigade in Kraken why was vaslovi
so crucial to the Russians I don't think
it was that crucial I guess they just
managed to get a photo there
is no direct line of sight to the River
from the other bank all those crossings
that is there is such a small Plateau
that arrives forests and so on so it is
possible to destroy the enemy from that
position and it was also possible to
establish the crossing because the
Russians did not see what was happening
there and you can control how they get
to this place and here there is direct
visibility that's why you control the
riverbank it was impossible to shoot
them from a long distance because there
is a plane that's why we couldn't cross
here and suffered losses and there is a
more convenient place there so we went
higher and had to go down
but here there are buildings narrow
roads mind approaches and so on
once again stop wow so why not fight
here the streets are not visible
everything is narrow and dug up there
are many large Capitol Buildings
one can place the 120 millimeter motor
here and it cannot be detected at all it
hit seven kilometers from the district
and that's it meaning you can fight what
was the final point that made of
Russians decide to flee from here it's
hard to say I guess they were already
running out of strength and the way they
were holding here I'm not a general I
don't know I have an impression that
they were meanwhile equipping their
position in
entrenching in the luhans region
Russians have been trying to win
sometime they had terrible losses here
they sent a whole mess of people to
death here the Russian 20th Brigade was
here it's so absurd that they have a
200th Brigade but also cooler to see
soldiers cargo 200 in addition they've
definitely changed the Brigade staff
around 88 times already that [__]
20th Brigade damn people who joined the
20th grade must be brave even though
they're all crazy there especially Putin
about all this numerology yes so somehow
it worked for them too yes and here
everything got tough here we fought to
the utmost here Russian Artillery Were
Striking when we entered this area after
we had to retreat from The Crossing we
entrenched at this Edge quite quickly
and got into it oh and then we were
holding it and developing further
advancement from here there was the key
Crossroad
we will now drive by
what what here they are sweet ones still
left
our soldiers were sitting here and there
were the positions over there were
infantry Vantage points in front our
boys were sitting there and adjusting
the fire from their positions there was
a mine barrier head but the Russians
removed it for some reason they were
probably going to attack three tanks
entered and there was funny in some way
the boys were sitting there and flying
their copters and then they said we see
three tanks but we said Point them into
artillery what the [__] kind of
artillery we could see them visually
damn just grabbed them right here in
short they grabbed some grenade launch
took up the defense they thought well
now we're nailing it there is actually
direct visibility now if it goes between
the trees there were still many leaves
then and the second one picked up the
copter and said I'm pointing their
artillery he told the coordinates
artillery guys responded are those your
coordinates are you an idiot you are
directly firing on yourself they are not
even 300 meters here well there is such
an episode the Infantry orientated
themselves they destroyed two tanks with
these shoulder launch and the third
escapes
it was eliminated later are these the
tanks you were talking about yes those
are the remains can we come over yes
come why not they are done
our boys gave them a good bashing
burnt uh Russians were lying here there
are even some items left
there were lots here
this is how it explodes and the tank
turn flies away from when the ammunition
is blown up
God from all sides
wow that was beautiful and the Russians
died in the fire and our soldiers
already found their way the Infantry oh
everything's all right
we're back down they marched forward and
on and on and pushed them out of here it
was a true Miracle uh you can't imagine
how the 92nd Brigade jumped uh over the
Osco River have you seen the shores
there I don't know how one can adjust
fire it's kind of a miracle so our boys
crossed here within literally within
days and we can say that due to the fact
that they cross the river and got here
now brought over and all the other
settlements are free yes yes so that was
already a technical matter there were a
lot of brutal battles here but I mean it
is indeed a miracle the way they crossed
over here they proved to be tough I have
no idea why there any second Brigade is
not present in the media I feel
disappointed about it I've been fighting
alongside them
that's the case because they don't want
to talk to the media I tell you it's
like everyone is being mentioned 72nd
Brigade is fantastic the 93rd damn it
the 80th and the 92nd is not damn it the
second week of the Ukrainian
counter-offensive the Russians had
already retreated from here and I was at
the headquarters then someone approached
the Brigade Commander Mr butusov has
arrived wait Noble tusovs we're working
no journalists let everyone do their job
well yeah nonetheless in fact on the one
hand there should be informational
Silence about some kind of offensive and
actual hostilities and on the other hand
everything that is taking place should
be recorded because it is emotionally
essential for society to show how
exactly it is happening and to show
people on the occupied territories that
there are territories that are already
being de-occupied even new journalists
the offensive in our recent history it
was the only offense over hundreds of
kilometers were covered in a few days
Russians were squeezed out who did it
again
[Music]
foreign
Bridge through which the wounded were
evacuated
is it a pedestrian bridge yes still
pedestrian civilians mostly go here
can we go there sure why not
[Music]
this was the bridge here
there was a checkpoint to regulate the
cars and the ambulance Vehicles drove up
here dropped the wounded and drove away
on the other side other people picked up
the wounded this was the way
both
evacuation was taking place yes probably
dozens of lives were saved
I guess so I believe probably even more
because otherwise one couldn't cross the
river and the guys are still walking
through here because it's faster
well currently such bridges are not
being restored very much
it takes time it's all about time
and you can't repair it just like that
you can't throw this passage from above
pictures are generally challenging to
repair
so what happens
your boy
and there are always several crashed
civilian cars in such places
always
and it's unclear whose those are and how
they got wrecked
[Music]
at least we had it this way
when you watch how they evacuate
Russians
when we fly a drone for example we look
and there are five wounded okay perfect
good job sometimes we even measured how
long it would take to get them damn
it's uh good if in a few hours some car
comes and evacuates him so Russians are
not really gross
into caring about their people that much
they shout quite hysterically on the
walkie-talkies Fox save us the boys are
dying fire is it about the all women who
will give birth to more soldiers concept
it seems that their Battlefield medicine
sucks I especially like watching the
videos showing how they wrap their arms
and legs with these medical harnesses
this is [__] creativity of some kind
of crap
there are no tourniquets in Pharmacies
with the relatives buy those
[__] the first aid kits from like uh
cars got the car first aid kids take the
harnesses from there yeah you guys don't
laugh ask your wives ask your
girlfriends or mothers for pads the
cheapest pads plus cheapest tampons you
know what a tampon is it for
me
just put it directly in there and it
swells with blood and presses the wound
edges
that's wonderful damn it my heart feels
warm and happy nothing is lost then we
will win this war as we go
you can come and settle in here right
now
hey Yura let's get to know each other
uh there is no need to film the kind of
luxury we have here
I'm actually kidding okay
let's get to know each other
before the full-scale War I was a deputy
of the key of city council a private
entrepreneur and public figure on the
24th of February my father called me
early in the morning around five o'clock
he said the war has started here I said
yeah who against tomb he said Russians
attacked don't be stupid I said attacked
whom he said us I said really he said
yes I said [__] seriously yes the first
thing I did I don't know why I just got
up and closed the gardens and then I
heard the planes flying over the house
I knew there would be challenges and
then the key city council was getting
ready for that still until the last
there were thoughts that it would be a
Russian offensive in dunbas consequently
I knew that if the pressure on our armed
forces of Ukraine was intense enough I
might be sent to a combat zone as a
signed contract with the territory
defense and I thought that it would be
effective because I have combat
experience but what after I close the
curtains I take the phone and start
calling through the contact list I am
calling those colleagues with whom I
signed a contract in territory defense I
am calling a brigade Commander I say
where's the meeting point and the 24th
of February the equipping process began
what is the advantage of territory
defense
first of all I have five people in my
unit who have previously completed
military service in the entire unit in
2014 two people a company commander and
another Soldier took part in battles
what are military subordination
hierarchy and the rest since the first
days it is pretty difficult as each
order was perceived not as an order but
as a starting point for discussion
during these eight months of full-scale
War as far as the military support
nation was concerned people had become
accustomed to it
nevertheless
what exactly is the advantage you should
look at the troops that I have and look
beyond the surnames into each person's
story they are powerful individual
personalities who have accomplished
something in their in their life in one
field or another or they were involved
in something meaningful and this kind of
symbiosis and bringing together people
with different skills capabilities and
abilities make it possible not only to
carry out official combat effectively
but also make it possible to implement
certain initiatives Mighty initiatives
before that he was engaged in the
reconnaissance of our Battalion and we
were basically under heavy fire day and
night from three sides I was seconded to
the reconnaissance unit and they also
assigned one or two quadricopter
operators when the copters were lifted
in the air it became evident that they
were not that many enemies and they were
not as Fierce as they might seem while
they were under constant fire moreover
we managed to establish communication
with the artillery what was the
information transmission procedure this
is why we were writing new guidelines I
had to write a report to the head of
reconnaissance of the Battalion to the
head of the reconnaissance to the deputy
Battalion commander and the deputy
Battalion Commander to the Battalion
commander and the Battalion Commander
has such a pile of all units deciding
which targets they shoot accordingly due
to the symbiosis of work we discover
four enemy tanks at a distance of six
kilometers from our position the four of
them stood there and Were Striking our
positions we passed this information
along a long Logistics exchange but no
reaction or answer comes there is not a
single artillery strike from our side we
have already forgotten about those tanks
we forgot that we requested the
artillery fire and at some point the
heavens began to thunder we understood
that somewhere ahead something was
starting to hit that zone we lifted the
copter to take a look and there is a
certain number of strikes I will not say
how many so the taxpayers feel okay and
there was a kilometer and a half missed
from the positions where there was a
non-statter Target at the Joint meeting
it became clear that something was wrong
let's depart from the general rules
shall we what did we mean here if the
targets are identified we immediately
report to our parent Battalion but at
the same time we immediately report to
the artillery chief he can immediately
side and identify whether the targets
are important or not and then direct
fire and over time we achieve from
vertical to horizontal yes the
information transmission chain from
artillery crew calculations that work
and see the target to the gun that hits
that Target not only there is a group of
aerial reconnaissance troops within the
unit but also a group of fire adjusters
the guys learned how to adjust artillery
Fire based on gaps and so on really
quickly we managed to combine the work
of territory defense in the field
Special Operations forces units of other
territory defense and the heroic
90-second mechanized Brigade I consider
the work they are doing astonishing
honor and praise to them due to the
coordination of all units and the
modernization of units from the inside
we began to train people in combat
operations and air reconnaissance
actively by some point we knew what was
in front of us what were the Dynamics of
changing positions where where are the
fire positions close ones far ones
Gunnery mlrs and so on as a result of
our teamwork I will keep repeating team
team all the time because I'm thankful
to God that I have the opportunity to
breathe the same air as these guys we
managed to push back the enemy who was
firing in us with 82 millimeter mortars
almost 12 kilometers away
that's as much as we saw at the time
they were all still approaching us with
tanks somehow maneuvering and so on but
we overcame the main fire pressure on
our positions and we knew that this
tactic proved to be effective based on
this organism of our unit we formed a
small Training Center together with
other adjacent training defense units we
help them establish the same teams with
their troops realizing that I have
troops of different ages and training
levels that we are already in combat
operations and we will not have the
opportunity to do Long training and
realizing that Personnel learns quickly
because people are smart we made a
decision to slowly transform our unit
into an artillery and air reconnaissance
unit
while at the same time holding positions
the team managed to train 70 of the
personnel and error reconnaissance today
I have a hundred percent of the
Personnel at the expense of my funds
volunteers who understand how the
kropovar combat software works the vast
majority knows how to adjust artillery
fire and I will not say how many air
calculations were also formed
are unit trained to perform the function
of artillery and error reconnaissance
[Music]
yeah we destroyed the mlrs yeah
foreign
because we need to recover unfortunately
there were losses it was necessary to
regroup in order to carry out the
assigned tasks in the future effectively
the Battalion went to restore and
resupply itself
we managed to prove to the Battalion
Commander rationally that the Personnel
of the fourth company with the company
commander and an irresistible desire to
remain in the combat zone since we
understand and know the sector and the
square very well we would rather not
lose the advantage we have gained
through systematic work the troops led
by the company Commander made their
decision
the military leadership
and we were left in the combat zone a
week and a half later
guys it starts the counter-offensive yes
it hasn't started yet um preparation
yeah the preparation starts we stopped
sleeping for
almost three weeks
this was an extremely complicated
process that required a high level of
focused activity especially since the
situation was constantly changing and
you had to make adjustments all the time
and so the team sat down
has been working non-stop almost without
sleep for about three weeks
broadly speaking the unit was divided in
three groups along with the other
secondary groups that went in three
directions
and so being in the battlefield area we
had to coordinate with the neighboring
unit to the left the neighboring unit to
the right and the neighbors and your
responsibility sector on the left and
right with a large number of adjacent
subunits
due to the activities of our unit
later I believe the information will be
disclosed how many armored vehicles and
Manpower we destroyed I believe that the
contribution of our unit each
representative this unit was extremely
crucial
there were also some fascinating stories
if they can be called that we managed to
crawl through the minefields without
casualties
the division at that time
whether you have faith in God or not
we can also call it the will of the
universe anyway during the first stage
of the counter-offensive operation our
unit did not have a single injury you
should nevertheless understand the
specifics of this job because for the
majority of the society and the aerial
Scout is some dude of the PlayStation
who sits in a warm place and watches
something from the outside
close aerial reconnaissance thanks to
gji mavic 3 and monsters 300 rtk
actually takes place in approximately to
the enemy
these people already have special
knowledge and this special knowledge
accordingly must be applied
professionally the unit already has a
group that uses Kamikaze drones the boys
were trained
as soon as there was the first sortie
they hit the Russian tank right away
usually they say that the first Pancake
is always a bit tricky yeah the boys
reported Commander minus the tank
felt like celebrating with light music
and Roomba here dumb dumb
oh wow
[Music]
sadly I have a number of wounded guys in
my unit they will watch your videos
someday we wish them good health and a
speedy recovery
it sometimes happens that boys get
concussed we have no idea how exactly we
know that there was shelling we asked
how do you feel in response all right
and they were indeed concussed they will
not report that they are not feeling
well for a few more days and will
continue their work do you even
comprehend the level of their motivation
and then you'll have the kind of
situation when you arrive at the
position look and he has a face as white
as snow and you will know this is a
concussion and what can we see in our
neighbors for instance 90 second
mechanized Brigade when others lose I
can say this way it's not that they lose
hope but initiative and then any second
infantry pushes forward
and what can
one say here
the 92nd Brigade is often appreciated
for the fact that many of its troops are
locals
that is even those who were now
deoccupying these lands where we are now
they were actually returning home
yes
very many from my Battalion there's a
lot of people who are originally from
these places that we are right now there
are a lot of servicemen both sergeants
soldiers officers who come from around
kupians and we're very pleased well I
can't say that it was pleasant what I
mean is that the boys they had a big
responsibility because their relatives
are here so when we finally liberated
these territories we had a lot of
emotions because we got here no matter
what
in the first days of the full-scale war
we only had one Defender killed
when there were street fights we
regrouped and started advancing from so
our unit liberated
no doubt it was a hard case in September
we tried to storm it twice basically it
was just when we broke through the
Russian defense and took the Ivanova
Village which is behind
when they started running away they ran
so fast that in five days we reached
kupians and in kupians near the river
our units met a powerful response
aircraft were flying there every 10
minutes from Russia our troops were
under very heavy fire there still well
done they resisted and they held on
in fact they have gained a foothold here
on the left bank right
yes they were entrenched on the Left
Bank
the Russians kept us from Crossing this
side with aircraft we needed three from
three to five missiles to destroy a
Target because we do everything with
aerial reconnaissance with all the
corrections needed
the Russians launched hundreds of
rockets mines and so on we have already
trained ourselves a bit to fight
according to the NATO standards but
still there are very many nuances
now it's it's also hard because there
are mobilized Russians during the day
for example we destroy many of them and
at night they take away the killed and
wounded and they bring back a batch of
new people and that's the way they do it
every single day to be honest I don't
know when they will run out of these
mobilized but
Russians announced that they have
already stopped the mobilization while
as a matter of fact it goes on in fact
it goes on and it'll go on further I
believe until some last drop about the
understanding about the amount of people
killed in the seriously wounded when
they'll finally get it and they won't
invade us this is our land and we will
not Retreat we will go on and on until
we liberate it to the borders
we Knight around two things the first is
the national value and state development
everyone sees this development in their
way but generally the vector where we
should move is most the same for
everyone and the second thing that
strongly unites us is the common enemy
or a common problem the Russian
Federation with its actions a full-scale
war burned all the bridges that could
potentially exist for centuries they
fell forever
now we will indeed have some there is a
swear word I won't say it but this part
of Ukraine which borders an insane
neighbor will definitely be highly
powerfully guarded and defended so that
there will never even be a thought that
Russia could what is happening now
those settlements that are closer to
Russia basically that are on the Russian
Border in uh
the locals kneeled before us there yeah
sure it was it was very nice those
collaborators who have been there
helping the Russian army they all they
all fled
people met us there one might say with
bread and salt they were delighted that
we came and expelled the damn Russians
among the troops
no matter how it sounds we are fighting
for our land for the city of Kiev region
so that rockets and missiles do not
strike it we fight for our families and
for our freedom what are Russians
fighting for performing the military
duty to the state some kind of
Romanticism they must be way too much in
TV shows right and so on and so on
however you could run out of Romanticism
quite quickly not even when you get
under Fire by sitting in a trench in
Sub-Zero weather without winter uniforms
and standard means of subsistence and
when you are in addition being shot at
and no you can be killed and then the
motivation changes radically the nature
of the enemy we are observing here how
do they use the untrained mobilized
troops they are placed in a position
with a small quarter left through which
you can bring reinforcements and now we
are noticing that behind them not only
in front of them yeah but behind them
the territory is mine why do Russians do
that so that under the onslaught of the
offensive of the Armed Forces of Ukraine
they could not regroup and Retreat back
when the first one started running away
and blow up the mines what is the
reaction of the rest will they stay in
the trenches so the 21st century in 2022
they operate using the methods of 1941
blocking troops and special services is
the abolition of serfdom in the Russian
Empire fake slaves I'm sorry but they
are indeed slaves non-slaves would not
have been tolerating one liter of damage
for 24 years what same state will
tolerate an executioner they torture
their people the standard of living
there has not improved at all if they
loot toilets I guess it's the kind of
currency in Russia like if you have a
toilet you're a cool guy in the village
a progressive one she returned from the
war he brought a stolen toilet let's go
there and see what he looks like this is
no place in the 21st century still they
don't know the
and that's why there's a faint chance
that someone will watch your materials
you film look at themselves in the
mirror and ask themselves maybe I'm I'm
not a surf maybe I need to change
something however I doubted very much
and how do we differ from them from
Russians
we differ because we we Ukrainian people
we are the kazakhs and this Kazakh
spirit it's alive our love for the
motherland and one's family it's a very
great motivation
our Battalion our unit liberated five
settlements in just four days
the boys knew that they had their
families here some boys even had their
relatives staying here during the
Russian occupation
we evacuated the children and the women
but some parents and old family members
they stayed here and they had been
waiting for the deoccupation
in any case Victory will be ours we're
going to take it we'll take what's ours
we don't need what belongs to someone
else but we will take what's ours and
we'll push the Russians to the borders
put up a fence dig a ditch and let
crocodiles in there and we'll also bring
back Crimea anyway
it is impossible to defeat the Ukrainian
Nation these are not even my words
moreover it cannot be destroyed the
victory will definitely be ours
addressing the civilians I would like to
thank everyone who stayed at their job
so continues to work supporting the
economy
those who left the country for security
reasons and continue to help the Armed
Forces of Ukraine and civilians by
organizing the humanitarian Aid Supply I
sincerely thank them the entire
Ukrainian nation
which has United in a single impulse is
now gaining freedom and Independence
during our previous Expeditions China we
first filmed cross gnfs
it's uh it is a town in the north of
slobesenchina yeah yeah and after that
at the end of May and the beginning of
June we also had an expedition
where we filmed a large episode
we had several Heroes who talked about
parking resisted the Russian invasion
and how they actually repels the primary
Russian full-scale offensive
um
Achi Community
recorded it in June
and did not release it this material was
actually published when the entire
delhachi Community had already been
deoccupied
we also had a series
released at that time our amazing story
is that we collected money for the farm
but the restoration process couldn't
happen so we transferred this money to
the comeback alive Foundation
apart from that we also filmed
in the khakib region
these are the episodes that came out
in general we are currently focusing on
smaller towns and Villages
most media are now publishing stories
about large cities
which we have already filmed before
so now we are trying to pay attention to
the smaller settlements and tell how the
resistance took place there
like that
[Music]
thank you